bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados la guerra en ucrania
podría afectar seriamente la estabilidad
de una región clave en el mundo el
ártico durante décadas en esta área del
planeta que rodea al polo norte se ha
mantenido una delicada política de
cooperación pero la guerra en ucrania y
el cambio climático podrían alterar este
frágil equilibrio desde 1996 se fundó el
consejo ártico un foro
intergubernamental que reúne a los 8
países con costa y canadá dinamarca
finlandia islandia y noruega rusia
suecia y eeuu de este foro también
forman parte las comunidades indígenas y
13 países observadores entre los cuales
china el consejo se creó con la
intención de hacer del ártico una zona
de cooperación principalmente en temas
de medio ambiente y no es para menos
puesto que aparte de la importancia para
los pueblos y ecosistemas locales se
trata de una región determinante para
regular la temperatura del planeta cómo
afecta a la guerra en ucrania a este
equilibrio las tensiones entre rusia y
otros estados del consejo ártico
iniciaron en 2014 cuando moscú anexionó
aquí mea a su territorio y comenzó a
fortalecer a su flota norte en la
península de kola cerca a finlandia y a
noruega
luego desde 2016 aumentó sus ejercicios
militares en la región
por su parte la otan con eeuu a la
cabeza también ha fortalecido su
presencia en el ártico y ha buscado
expandirse y ahora con la guerra actual
en ucrania cada vez es más posible una
unión de suecia y finlandia a la alianza
militar esto significaría que todos los
países árticos 1 - rusia formarían parte
de la otan o algo que moscú ve como una
amenaza ya en abril el kremlin dijo que
los recientes ejercicios militares de la
alianza en noruega el cold response 2022
no contribuyen a la seguridad en la
región también amenazó con desplegar
armas nucleares y misiles supersónicos
en el báltico si la afiliación de suecia
y finlandia se llega a materializar y es
que moscú no es cualquier actor en la
región rusia posee el 53 por ciento de
la costa del ártico y se ve a sí mismo
como el principal jugador en terreno
pero además de las tensiones por la
guerra hay otro factor clave el
derretimiento del a raíz del cambio
climático está modificando
drásticamente el panorama en los últimos
30 años el hielo más grueso de la región
ha perdido el 90 por ciento de su
superficie en verano y se calcula que
para 2040 podría no haber hielo en esta
época del año en resumidas cuentas se
está creando un nuevo océano en el polo
norte que cambia el tablero del juego y
lo convierte en centro de intereses
económicos y militares por un lado por
las reservas naturales se estima que en
el ártico hay grandes cantidades de
petróleo y gas natural según el servicio
geológico de eeuu en el círculo polar
ártico podría haber el 13% del petróleo
y el 30% del gas natural aún por
explorar en el mundo y la mayoría de
estas reservas de combustible se
encuentran cerca a las costas rusas por
otro lado el ártico también podría
convertirse en una importante vía se
trata de la ruta del mar del norte que
recorre la costa rusa aunque está
actualmente bloqueada por agua congelada
durante la mayor parte del año con el
deshielo
podría alterar para siempre el flujo del
comercio mundial reduciría
considerablemente muchas rutas que
actualmente pasan por los canales de
suez o de panamá por ejemplo según el
instituto danés de estudios
internacionales la distancia entre
yokohama en japón y hamburgo en alemania
se recortaría en un 42 por ciento
estas nuevas perspectivas han aumentado
el interés en el dominio de este
territorio donde con frecuencia las
fronteras no están estrictamente
trazadas y algunos países tienden a
reclamar más de lo que otros reconocen
esto también ha impulsado a rusia a
fortalecer su posición la potencia
euroasiática lleva años invirtiendo en
puertos y bases militares
una apuesta que sigue renovando con
nuevos sistemas de armas convencionales
y nucleares se calcula que para 2019 el
kremlin contaba con una flota de 40
rompehielos y que trabaja en otra más
potente y la otan no se ha quedado atrás
eeuu y la alianza también han reforzado
su presencia militar y washington está
invirtiendo en nuevos rompehielos para
abrirse camino en la exploración de
recursos
pero por si fuera poco existe otro
jugador clave china el gigante asiático
que a priori forma parte del consejo
ártico como observador aspira a ser una
gran potencia polar y en los últimos
años el beijing ha expresado sus
intenciones de acceder tanto a la ruta
del ártico como a los recursos naturales
unas aspiraciones que no han gustado a
eeuu que asegura que sólo hay dos grupos
de países los estados árticos y los
estados min o árticos sin embargo china
ha hecho recientemente grandes
inversiones en infraestructura y en
explotaciones mineras en el ártico en
países como rusia islandia y groenlandia
a la par ha estado construyendo una
flota de buques rompehielos en medio de
este panorama cambiante está por verse
si los intereses económicos políticos y
militares pondrán fin al equilibrio que
ha regido en la región o si la necesidad
de colaboración hasta ahora existente
permitirá su estabilidad si les sirve el
vídeo para entender los intereses
geopolíticos que rodean al ártico los
esperamos en otro episodio de 5 minutos
entre las 24 y france24 punto com